foreign
hi everyone I'm Alexis if you had seen
on the program and might have said Amit
uh unfortunately he couldn't make it so
I'm giving the talk in place of him
um but yeah so our uh this is Joint work
with riddy Yuval ayal Paul and this is
our work on hard languages and
emperors.comp and music groups from
unstructured hardness so there's a lot
of words in this title
um to get like and Peterson P you have
music proofs you have unstructured
hardness so I'm going to just break
these down uh one of the time uh
starting with MPS
so MP intercept column P are languages
for which if you have a witness you can
officially check whether it's in the
language and if it's not a language so
you have this sort of two-sided uh thing
you can check
and in fact we don't actually have that
many candidate hard language and
emptiness at Columbia and in general
they're pretty highly structured so as
some examples we have factoring we have
some statistic games conduction
um Cats games we have some construction
from one-way permutations but we don't
really have much more than this
unless you're talking about the promise
problem world of yeah hard hard means
not empty uh that's what it'll mean for
the talk
uh but for promise problems we do
actually have a lot more hard languages
but for the focus of the talk we'll be
focusing just only on languages uh not
promise problems and the reason is that
the question of Interest we have is
actually pretty simple for promise
problems and non-discencing
so a total unclear kind of how hard MP
intersect co-n-p actually is
so most of the current candidates we
have are broken by Quantum algorithms so
factoring is and then one-way
primitations we really only know how to
build from factoring industry log which
are also broken by Quantum algorithms
additionally there's some simple
computational models uh working in plugs
on now that shows that P equals NP
intercept Co and P for the system trees
and we actually don't know any complete
languages for these models
and you know in the community there are
some people that don't really think this
is hard for example Peter sharnock
thinks that factoring is in p and
therefore not hard
and then uh and Jack Edmond he actually
has a rock in his front yard where he's
in grade but he thinks that people's
Amphitheater
so not everyone thinks that this class
is hard
um and that's kind of what we'll be
exploring is how hard is this class and
what can people
actually they're different that's why
you need the fact that you have
characterization for when you have
matching and non-matching that it
doesn't mean that you have a polynomial
time algorithm that's why it works
maybe he thought it was a generalist
thing
so yeah maybe if you think it's not
equal to make your own rock and stick it
in a yard across the street
yeah have a little war between them but
yeah so
as I mentioned these candidate hard
languages we do have our highly
structured and one question we can ask
is can we build a hard language from
sort of unstructured assumptions
does matter should I not care
uh so yeah it doesn't really matter
um for this I mean just because you you
made a point and you're focusing on
languages right so much
if you want
okay conclusion is about languages the
Assumption doesn't need to be about see
yeah
you can make a canonical form for the
prime factorization and ask is the iPad
of this canonical form
I think so yeah orthod like uh some
crypto primitive from Factory
for example
yes okay so uh what do we mean by
structured assumptions
uh so yeah here's a quiz which of these
do you think are unstructured
assumptions and I mean I haven't really
described what unstructured is but you
can look at these and be like okay maybe
factoring is structured but uh what
about random oracles
um
yeah there is some structure in uh
random molecules but uh actually for the
stock we're going to be saying that
random oracles are probably one of the
least structured of these
so
yeah I mean
You could argue that random oracles are
still pretty structured um but they are
infrastructure is unrealism
pretty much any property either holds
with probability one relative to a
random Oracle or probability zero
relative to a random Oracle so in some
in this formal sense all random oracles
look alike
thank you
it's just a random function
if you want to machine that generates a
conjectured classes
yeah so I mean we can think of random
oracles are a random function so it in
general won't have like linear structure
for example like lwe or like strong
algebraic structure and I mean random
objects are kind of as close as we can
sort of get to unstructured objects so
we'll use random Oracle kind of as what
we Define for unstructured hardness will
be ones that you can build from random
oracles
and then as a consequence will also
allow anything that can be built from
random Oracle so also kind of be
considered unstructured
for example random oracles are one way
and collagen resistant so you could kind
of think of one-way functions as being
an unstructured assumption because if
you just took a random function it's and
give you Black Box access it should be
one way
uh yeah so we're talking about languages
relative
so we will Define uh some language Lo
where L is defined relative random
and we could also say injected one-way
functions uh could be considered
unstructed hardness because if you have
a random length tripling function then
with very high probability you won't
have any collisions and therefore
objectives
on the other hand all these other things
we don't know how to build heuristically
from random oracles
um so pull my permutations uh for
example we don't know how to build that
from random functions and we can really
only build it from things like Factory
industry work so we will break it down
like this
um and say that unstructured things are
everything in the random Oracle regime
and structure things are everything else
and you know why is this kind of a
reasonable breakdown
so if we look at sort of random Oracle
separations for complexity classes
there's recently been a lot of really
exciting work in it so starting with the
work of Ben and McGill they showed how
to separate PMP and colon p by random
oracles
there's another work that shows that the
polynomial hierarchy is infinite
relative to it and then a very very
recent work
um from Fox shows that you can separate
btp and PPP uh relative to random Oracle
with respect to search phones
so there's been a lot of work a lot of
interest in the complexity Community
specifically regarding Oracle
separations of complexity classes
and in the crypto Community uh the
reason part of the reason we care is
that uh it's we might think that random
Oracle separations could potentially
give us actual real world instantiations
if we uh you know replace the random
Oracle with some hash function
so there's this hypothesis that says if
you can separate them
um with random oracles then you can
separate them without random oracles
which has been proven to be false for ID
and Q space but it's still possibly true
for uh simpler complexity classes like P
and MP intersect Co and P and there
haven't been counter examples for much
simpler classes
and so as I mentioned before we can kind
of if you have a
separation in the random Oracle model
you would just replace the random Oracle
with a hash function then that gives a
candidate
um real world uh separation
these are some of the reasons why we
care about the random
[Music]
so the question then more specifically
is can we build a hard language in amphi
nurse at komp from random oracles and
this has been open since uh Ben and Gill
uh four years ago
so yeah so what's known uh again we
don't know the separation and in fact
there's another work by tardos that
shows some difficulties if you try to do
the separation
and if you're just trying to use basic
crypto then we actually have some
possibility results
um from Black Box constructions so you
can't build it just from one-way
functions and even if you assume IO
which is extremely powerful there's also
no black box instructions uh from
injected one-way functions in Idaho
and this rules out a whole bunch of
crypto because you can use IO one-way
functions to build
yeah
and what our work does is the follow-up
so it just does that extent like if
Black Box separation for random Oracle
saying that you can have like a black
box a lens or uh yeah so this
construction does not deal with the
random Oracle model it just says suppose
we're trying to build a language and
experience.conp but not MP
assuming only let's say injected one-way
functions IO then you can't do that if
you use a black box construction oh
yeah
yes I just want to mention that uh you
don't actually get this result
from either my work with Manuel or or
Stephen riddich's work alone you need
the results several years later of Khan
stock
s
con
snacks and Smith
with a y
that I will add the difference
skin from remarkable and does it give a
language in anything language is a
commitment transcript plus uh
right so you have
July
a transcript plus a bit let's see one
actually the minimum when the human is
really accommended to one it's in the
language if it's not it's coming to zero
then it's not in the language your
certificate will be the dismissment
information
so here we're dealing with end here
technology which is not randomized so we
would want it to be like perfectly
finding it
for that to work foreign
so yeah so actually for uh promise
problems you can build it from just like
inject the one-way functions or assuming
uh up is not equal to P so uh yeah I
mentioned earlier but uh promise
problems this is actually fairly easy to
build um
thank you
so our main theorem shows that uh if
there's this injective only functions
then we have an oracle separation
between p and engineers
and in fact uh the way we kind of get
around the impossibility results before
uh it's mainly because we use a
non-black box RECenter
injections
yeah in the previous results assumed
that the P equals empty in the real
world
to get to
um
the previous result by uh const Saxon
Smith
was that if P equals NP in the real
world
then P to the O is uh NP to the O
intersect colon ptdo is an infinitely
often average
uh P to the o
or a random Oracle so it doesn't
contradict this in any sense
so
yeah like yeah and if you assume that P
is different from NP intersect colon p
in the real or BPP is different prevent
the inters that go into in the real
world and
P to the U is going to be different
by the same problem
so it's
[Music]
um so yeah one of the nice things about
our theorem is that it's actually a
constructive proof so if you were to
replace the Oracle with the hash
function then we actually have a
polytime algorithm that can give you a
candidate language
um that's in and Peter said column P but
not MP
well this all this process basically
allows you to build a whole bunch of
candidate languages that might be an nmp
intersect column P but not mp uh just
kind of assuming maybe that your
cryptographic cache function will work
kind of like random Oracle
verification process
or
um
hardness and MP intersections
differently problems with one solution
for this one percentages
is
[Music]
okay
you know so basically we're using the
language in GT not in an RP to sort of
replace the injected one-way function in
our kind of construction
does it have a fixed input or foot size
or is it for all yeah so questions about
what are what the random Oracle looks
like so here the random Oracle you can
think is an infinite name
for everyone
uh however when we use it for inputs of
fixed planes we'll only ever use some
fixed length of the Oracle and you could
kind of think of that if you wanted as
like end it's the end it's you could
always transform some finite Lansing too
but yeah the technical model of the
Oracle is just an infinitely long bit
screen
so yeah so uh to build this we actually
have another result which is our main
new ingredient for this is we build a
Music proof system in the random Oracle
model
so uh here we're using only random
oracles so there's not going to be a
structured random string at all uh you
could think of it kind of like the URS
model because you could build urs's from
random oracles
and uh no we don't already have
different Fiat Shamir could this only
gives music arguments which hold for
computationally bounded proofers
as our second result we show that there
exists an unbounded proofer I'll get
back to that the prover is not efficient
uh Music proof system for NP and the
random Oracle model
and if you just really don't like random
oracles then we actually uh describe
some objects called the Delta dance
studio random hash function that you
could build and also use to instantiate
mentorships so here
um assuming there exists a Delta dance
prhf where Delta is just some constant
that you can officially approximate
then we have a Music proof system for MP
in the US model
before I go into a little bit more about
the music Bruce let me just Define what
The Skeleton Dance krhf is
oh sorry yeah URS is uh the uniformly
random spring model which means the
prover and the verifier both have access
to a uniform administring this can be
contrasted with the structured random
spring model where the string doesn't
have to be uniform yeah
so it's a constant and there's an
algorithm that allows you to
approximate like n Bits of it to within
like 1 over 2 to the n in efficient time
so polynomial time
so basically the the verifier will have
to use this constant so they'll need to
basically create some good enough
approximation of it for every input
language
so what is this uh to the random hash
function so first it's pseudorandom
which means if h on a random input
should look random should be
indistinguishable from a random element
in the code domain
uh we also have density which says that
uh if you take a random element the
codomain it should be in the image of H
with uh probability really close to
Delta
and then finally we have this new
property we call it premature Randomness
which says uh that if you have two ways
of taking X and Y where the first way
you pick a random X you set y equal to H
of x
then this should be indistinguishable
from picking first a y from the image of
H and then setting X to a random
pre-image of Y
this is kind of an element of our proof
so
[Music]
yeah this is a computationally
indistinguishable yeah
sample randomly in the domain
uh yeah so X is a random element with
the name use a random element the
codomain and Y through it's a random
element of the image
an inverse function just takes a random
Improvement yeah
how does this relate to known
assumptions see what any other known
assumptions
um so yeah I mean it's sort of like uh
so we actually
uh don't know how to construct this from
standard assumptions they are satisfied
by a random Oracle uh but you can think
of the first one of being kind of like a
prg
um
and then this pseudo premature
Randomness is kind of new
um and the density uh so I guess if you
had for example an injective
um
injective prg that was expanding by one
bit
that would satisfy this because the
density would be one half
but
um yeah we don't currently have any
candid constructions for it right now
but it is Satisfied by a random Oracle
and so we could conjecture that you know
your favorite hash function
might be one yeah
over the range
thank you
so yeah so these are our three theorems
and let me go into a little bit more
about uh newspapers
so it's a one-way permutation does this
satisfy this or no uh a one-way
permutation would say yeah because the
density would be one and then the
let's go to the rent well it'd have to
be
no it had this due to random permutation
yeah so it would be yeah and then
sensors only at only every one element
of the
um it would satisfied previously the
randomness because uh every element of
the range would be equally likely and
have exactly one pre-image
said you don't know
I'm sorry from any unstructured
um standard assumption so this follows
from one of my permutation
um it would follow yeah I think so yeah
it would follow for more information
over like zero one to the N or something
yeah one way permit yeah
yeah so yeah sorry about that uh yeah we
don't know the Constructor from any
unstructured assumptions uh you could
build it from all my information you
could also build it from
um
prds if they're expanding by like K bits
or something or k it's a constant good
but we don't really know how to build
injectabies for example
sorry sorry
so identity doesn't satisfy this because
it's not super random
ly yeah
yeah
um
so what we need Delta actually to be
less than one strictly
um so it has to be between zero and one
strictly speaking and can't be one
so
is it baked into the definition that
it's expanding or tricking the number of
like n versus m or uh so here it's kind
of in Delta so I didn't write it here
but uh Delta needs to be a constant
strictly between zero and one so it
can't be it has to be expanding a little
bit but it can't be too exciting
right I guess it doesn't have to be
expanding if it has collisions
so like if it went from n Bits to 2N
then that definitely wouldn't satisfy
that because Delta wouldn't be a
constant
station can work because the domains
exercise
it would depend so yeah I do didn't like
you could add stuff to the range and if
it was hidden with whether or not it was
in the range
but I got to think about it more yeah
yeah
so is conditioned to just the equivalent
to saying most elements have about the
same number of pre-images
uh if if most elements have about the
same
numbers but it's just computationally
hard I guess so yeah
oh is that computationally yeah all
these are computations
okay yeah
oh yeah for example a k regular function
where every uh
output has the same number of pre-images
uh satisfies to the randomness
and in fact we do know how to build
something that satisfies 130 from an
objective prg but not
so okay uh back to music groups
um so let me just explain briefly what
music group is so the proverb is trying
to prove that X is his own language sort
of thing L is being an answer language
and here in our setting we're doing uh
the unbounded quiver setting so this is
for the same definition it's the
original work
um
uh and the reason you know Unbound
approver is not great if you want to
like actually use this in the real world
but it's uh sufficient for our purposes
here and it would be nice and follow-up
work to maybe try to make an efficient
improver
and then we have three properties so
completeness says that if everyone's
correct you're like everyone's honest
then the previous should be able to
prove true things to the verifier
soundness says that the approver is
dishonest uh then they shouldn't be able
to prove false makes the verifier and
here we're in the proofs which means
that the cheating quiver can be
undoubted as well
and then zero knowledge says roughly
that
um the verifiers didn't learn anything
more except the exits in the language
which we can model by having a simulator
that simulates the transcripts that we
would receive okay
yeah this is uh yeah so this is the
random one this is just the plain URS
model or just the URL
in a random Oracle model uh here rather
than having a URS you'll just have query
access to random Oracle and then zero
knowledge is for verifiers that can only
make polynomial in many queries to
random Oracle so we'll require the
simulator to also simulate the random
Oracle I put this in quotes because it's
kind of more like a game to either query
the Oracle or the wellness
yeah the simulator needs to generate uh
like queries that look like
like cool along with uh what the proof
just looks like and they would need to
do it because they need to have their
Oracle they simulate uh correspond to
kind of what the proverb
s
on data they can see all of the oracles
verifiers now
found it
uh so here we're saying that you have so
the prover basically gets all the Oracle
they can do whatever they have they have
as much time as they want the verifier
complexity
uh yeah so the prover has unbounded uh
access to the randomly yeah
so computational complexity here
uh yes the approver also hasn't got a
query questions
so what do we have for previous work on
physics so we're dealing with the yellow
box which is music groups again security
against Unbound improvers uh where this
you have a uniform random string
note that in the structured random
string model uh where this string is not
uniformly random you can get more
results
um but uh one of the things we know is
that we have like well my expectations
stealing all these things but uh these
are kind of structured hardness
assumptions
um and not postpone them except maybe
audio
and if you want you know it from like
one-way functions for example then you
have to go the structurally random
string model or music arguments and the
reason why lattices is down here like
why doesn't only functions just do
everything it's because like us they
have an Unbound approver so the lattice
constructure has a bounded paper which
is nice but we actually don't have any
lattice constructions in the URS and
proof-based model
so if you want unstructured hardness uh
again Fiat Shamir can give you a random
Oracle model or you can go to structured
random strings
um but I guess that is structure by
having the structured random straight
in our work we show how to basically get
random oracles or or music proofs from
either random oracles or Delta dense pra
chips and so suppose previously unknown
how to build this from unstructed
hardness
and I'll now go into kind of how to
construct these
any questions on the results
so first we're going to try to separate
being an empty Center set column
so our ingredients here for Simplicity
I'll just talk about the injective
one-way function versions although you
can build it from a language and you can
not RP
and then we'll have a Music proof in the
random Oracle model for the language
which is just the set of all uh y's that
have a premise so all the Y's that are
um in the image of that
and our language is actually pretty
simple it's just that y i Pi where y uh
has to have a printage x and we require
the ith bit of x to be one and Pi should
be a valid proof that y has a payment
and if you uh assume this language you
would just replace x with W or W the
unique witness that um Y is in RL double
Prime
anyway
that's a good question yeah so what we
build is we build uh one that has
perfect completeness it has the physical
soundness uh which is kind of adapted
meaning that uh the probability that the
Oracle allows for false proofs is
negligible and then we have a
computational zero knowledge
so kind of uh assuming it's perfectly
sound which is not uh so we'll go back
statistical soundness so then you can
actually show the L's in your feet or to
the o
and the way you do this is you can first
just check if the proof Pi is valid if
it's not valid then it can't be in The
Language by definition
and otherwise then there better be a
single unique uh there better be a
pre-image right X and because f is
injective then this x is unique
so that X is going to be the witness and
you can check that it's the correct
pre-image and then you'll just check if
I put this one or not
OMP you can kind of just do the same
thing except you just check at the bit
of zero so the proof kind of ensures
that you definitely have this uh
pre-image X and since there's only one
you can just check whether the bit is
zero
the deal with statistical sound is I
won't go into it but um you can use the
Boreal cantelli Lemma to deal with that
um and then why is it uh not in P let's
go
can you just show it again just just
for a second
it's not a promise level yeah
why is this not a promise language uh
what would be why does every y has a
pre-image so the proof pie if the proof
the proof perfectly sound
then it must have a primage because uh
if it didn't have a pre-image then
perfect soundness would say that there
is no proof that would verify because
you can efficiently verify instances
that are out of the Promise by running
the verified so perfect soundness would
say if y does not have a free image then
there would be no proof
proof so if we know it verifies then
that guarantees by the perfect sound of
physics that there must be exactly one
there must be advantage in this case
exactly one because f is uninjected
yeah so this is in some sense of
chlorophy this is scaling up the
commission which works in case of
Promise problems
uh yeah a little bit
serious
ly something uh yeah so right now we
have perfect found this uh if we're
dealing with statistical soundness uh I
guess but essentially what you do is you
say you can prove using the world
cantelli theorem and our soundness bound
that with probably one over the random
Oracle then you only have a finite
number of bad oracles that allow for bad
proofs and then you can make a new music
proof that just removes all the fat
oracles the group Parts confuses
there is no no so there were there is no
URS we just have pnb have access to Iran
Oracle
yeah you could use a random or called
The Constructor URS if you wanted uh by
just taking some part of the input
domain and saying that output is the URS
but there is no you are a separate
funding
okay uh yeah so uh a very high level uh
what we can prove is that based on our
sound that's down that would probably
won over the brand of Oracle there
exists only a finite number of oracles
that admits like bad things
and then we can construct a new V Prime
that for those finite number of bad
oracles would Brute Force complete the
answer
and then therefore
um
it's like perfect sudden it's like
appropriate
yeah so our definition of soundness was
sort of this uh that was set with
negotiable probability uh look the over
the randomness of just the oracle
uh you can't have bad things
you didn't get that it's fine don't
worry about it um
so why is it not in here though
so if we assume that the you know the
opposite soon supposedly
though with some publications of zero
then there's a theorem from Ben and the
Gill which shows that there must exist
um decider that basically works for all
of the languages so the statement itself
would talk about a decider for each
language hello but here uh the theorem
allows us to kind of change the
qualifier order and say that there would
be the cider event that works for every
elf
um with probability one
okay if you have the decider you can
invert the woman
so you have a live you can just make a
fake proof that y has a famous because
um you have a missing simulator and then
you just run D and uh if Pi was a real
proof that why had a pretty image then D
would tell you whether x i and zero one
and because uh by zero knowledge you
shouldn't be able to tell whether or not
you know use the simulator or real proof
and so therefore D will output whether
or not x i is zero one correctly and
that will give you X image
so basically we're just extracting X
from this by using the fact that we can
make fake proofs from the visit
um these are our results again and now
uh how do we construct this improved in
the random Oracle model
so our starting point will be uh the
work of fls adoption near which shows
that you can build music pre-tran piece
from one-way permutations in the URS
model
and our idea is that we're just going to
try to replace the one-way permutations
with a random Oracle and
um note that if you want to replace the
URS with a random Oracle that's pretty
simple to do
okay so how do they do it well first
they build music proofs and what they
call the hidden bits model and then they
show how to build the hidden bits model
using a URS and a woman permutation
now unfortunately we weren't able to
instantiate the hidden bits model with
uh random Oracle so instead what we do
is we build an as it proves for a new
model that we call the Z10 probability
of its model and then show how to
instantiate that one with the random
Oracle
so let me just describe what this is but
first I'll describe what the hidden bits
model is
on the hidden bits model you can think
of it as you have kind of the URS a
uniformly random string except it's
hidden in some way
and by hidden we mean that the prover
gets to see all of it so they get
everything but the verifier does not get
to see anything at the start
and then the prover can send across to
approved pi and open any of the bits
that they want
so here uh the previous to see
everything the verifier gets to see only
the bits that the Proverbs uses
and the prover importantly does not get
to choose uh the bits of the
the hidden bit string
and then B will just accept or reject
again it's like the US model except here
um the verifier only gets to see certain
bits and those bits are chosen by the
group
so
suppose we want to instantiate this with
a random Oracle and a URS I'm adding a
URS onto the random Oracle just explore
to make it a little bit easier to write
down but you could build a URS using the
random Oracle as well
so one thing you might think to do
um is you could maybe do some inverse
function whatever that means we'll get
back to that but you would maybe want o
of x i equal to Y and then because o is
one way there should be a hardcore bit
function you can set RI to be the hard
coordinated X right
why might this be nice well o is hard to
improve so it should be B only gets to C
right the Y's if we have a Urus and so
therefore they shouldn't be able to
learn X and also it shouldn't be able to
learn r
however the proverb who's unbounded can
just Brute Force compute all the X's
and then send over x i as kind of their
opening to our eye
and then the verifier can just check
that it's a correct opening and computes
the hardcore bit
of course there are a couple problems uh
I said oh inverse but like what if
there's not a pretty image
um so in that case you know R is just
undefined there's no plainage like how
do you compute hardcore bits nothing
um so in this case we lose completeness
and you could think okay maybe I'll
change the parameter to my scheme so
that I'm compressing so every single y
always has a pretty image
but actually that's even worse because
now you have multiple pre images and if
you have multiple framages you know that
means R can sure the prover the cheating
improver can pick any of these R's to
use
so they have some control over what bits
show up in Hidden bit string and that
ends up completely breaking down this
so actually uh if you're building this
from random oracles you're going to have
to have at least one or both of these
problems
that's just based on how the parameters
work
and you know and flow has to get around
this by just using one of my
permutations and in fact that's how they
instantiate the model since they use the
money permutation and then neither these
problems so
we'll kind of need to use a different
idea
so for us we're going to set the I bit
equal to one depending not on what
Supreme is but on whether or not it has
a cringe
it will look like this
so we'll set the if bit equal to zero if
there is a pre-image and it'll be one
otherwise
oh yeah
in previous slide so if you're ready
if the student bit model you can do it
not just in one implementation but also
from things like uh verified functions
so you could
just think about them as blocks rather
than just yeah and just apply your
animal in that four Direction but not on
y but on like y comma s where s is like
something that shows like approver uh
but you use the same s for all the bits
or something like this and then improver
still has some leverage because you can
like decide after the fact what this s
is but you can sort of
um
um amplify the hardness so that like the
the space of this is does not allow you
to actually sort of change things are
done like
uh we haven't really thought about
it but
okay put this around I'm not saying
constructive URL from same sort of
try this approach with the random okay
but never mind
specifically maybe we can talk about it
afterwards
this will be our news team and uh why
might we be disappeared well you know
the uh for uh random Oracle you can't
really easily determine if there's a
free image uh the best you can do is
just like try to guess what the pain it
is and then check if it's correct
um and what the prover can do is they
can if there is a premise they can
complete it and send it over to verifier
could be checked and if they're not a
pretty much they're just going to say
have an advantage now is to immediately
bring red flags because the Brewer can
lie about that I mean if there is a
famous they're like oh no there's no
free image I lied so yeah but you know
roughly what how many are gonna have no
preeminine that's correct that's how
you're gonna catch them yeah so we will
be using some statistical texts
so spoilers that's what we'll be doing
in the future is using some statistical
tests to balance how many times they can
lie yeah
yeah so our solution for this uh is just
to find a new model that lets you lie in
this one-sided okay
[Music]
uh yeah so the perfect completeness we
will also
um amplify
the sample ability there's really few
changes
it just tells you whether the hidden
bits are zero or one maybe the entire
little bit string is zero
that's correct I'm going to check
there's enough dreams
here basically yeah so I believe
actually was like a very high
probability oh yeah yeah
I think what we did was we first uh we
did the transformation uh when we built
this proof and then
um do the transformation for that later
for the soundness
um yeah we did do that
so this is in this model is just the
same as the hidden Bismol except the
prover can lie when the hidden bit is
zero so if it's zero they can lie about
and say it's one and B will receive the
other one or zero of their choice
and we call it contemporable because
this looks kind of like a z channel from
information Theory and this really
captures the ability that the prover can
Lie by saying there's no preemage when
their action is one
but the honest prover is never going to
lie they'll just open them to the
correctives
so as you know it's pointed out uh P
actually can't lie as much as they want
because uh you know if they lied and
said everything's on the verifier would
be like that that seems unlikely so I'm
going to reject
uh yep yeah
okay
um
yeah okay so
okay sorry about that uh yeah so we're
gonna add some stickle tests and um what
we can show is that if you assume that
the hidden bitspring is actually a
structure if it's a cycle graph then
I'll skip through this but in fact uh
this also works with Z capable and a bit
small so if you stream a structured
hidden bit string then actually it still
works because flipping zero to one is
not going to help you
um on the other hand if R is on the
cycle like what they do about that so
but fls did we'll show you it's a clever
way of sampling uh graphs so that you
got one uh there's a cycle graph with
high probability
um so there's a protocol
um and
uh basically there will be these good
matrices and these bad matrices and you
want to have at least one good Matrix
and then the proof will work
but a cheating improver can turn good
bait repeats the bad ones by adding ones
and invalidating them and they can also
turn bad matrices into good ones by
pretending they were actually good ones
and so we sort of need to constrain how
many good matrices can become bad
matrices
I'm skipping so much but uh the way we
do that is you'll kind of check
basically for
how many ones are in The Matrix and
um
basically any good Matrix that becomes
bad we'll have to have at least n plus
one ones but there aren't enough bad
matrices you can
I can go into this more in detail
afterwards if you're interested
uh so yeah so what we do is we increase
sparsity matrices and we add statistical
chests yeah
so these are main results and a couple
of some questions and unconditional
article separation would be great
efficient proverb would also be great
and then if we could instantiate this
from I guess standard unstructured
assumptions uh the Delta defense pH that
would be great
thanks
Who's online